Oh what's up everybody let me get the
the webcam going alright alright
morning everybody welcome back it's the
fourth of July if you're from the US
happy fourth of July to you guys happy
Independence Day the streams do not stop
you guys we are still going on the
fourth of July you guys are having a
good one
you guys have been safe and healthy yeah
yeah and it's been a it's been a crazy
week we've been working on a lot of fun
stuff at corridor got a couple of videos
that came out we've got the stuntman
react came in out coming out a couple
hours ago actually with Aaron Tony super
nice guy and Ren's
360 god camera came out yesterday I
think and I'm still working on that
Domino's video man there's so many VFX
on that but yeah it's a good time thank
you for joining thank you for hopping on
in here guys we're doing something very
interesting today which was definitely
inspired by man I wish I had the
original link here basically there's a
video going around where someone like
opens up an electrical socket and
there's this hidden world inside from
like behind the electrical socket let me
see if I can find it
yeah this is I think this is it and you
go in here and there's like a little
tiny room inside and I think this guy
has like a whole bunch of these these
are so cool definitely gets me going
mozu it looks like his name is yeah
check out mozu and yeah it's I guess he
does all these like little tiny little
craft projects like this and this gets
me super amped and very very creative
and I want to do something very similar
inside of obscenity so I shot this
footage the link to the footage is
actually in the description if you guys
would want to check that out and do this
yourself but let me get going on this
single monitor and you guys can see if I
scrub through here you know very similar
I just opened up this kind of electrical
outlet and zoom up into what will be you
know a 3d tracked world whatever we want
to do it could be a room it could be an
outdoor scene it could be literally
anything but we'll figure that out once
we track it so that's the first thing is
figuring out how to track this yes I did
shoot it on a phone so that was on
purpose I wanted to make it feel as
natural as possible and you know I kind
of zoomed in here to get get up in here
to see definitely give some parallax so
that we can actually move around our 3d
world and we'll comp it right inside so
this is gonna be a fun one
all this stuff all this we don't need to
track it's just from this point on when
I open up boom this little panel is when
we'll need to track it so we can start
the track from like back here frame
maybe frame like 100 or something and
it's foot and we'll go as far as we need
to go so inside of cinema is there they
actually have like a really powerful
camera tracker it's really really cool
and it's got some really nice features
that I wish other
trackers had the aftereffects trackers
nice it's definitely like the fastest
and easiest one to use but it doesn't
always yield the best results and I
always find that like for me I like that
I like to use different camera trackers
just if one can't achieve you know what
I'm going for then I'll go to the next
one and I usually work between After
Effects tracker cinema 4d tracker in
Buju those are like my three that I'll
switch between but yeah for those of you
guys who don't know I did a sea graph
presentation that'll be coming out later
this month with Macs on and I'm doing
I'm talking about the entire workflow
process from like when you're going for
photo real CG elements composited it
into live-action footage it's the whole
workflow and it always starts with you
know obviously shooting your footage but
once you've shot your footage we want to
we want to track that footage right we
want to get a virtual camera of that
tracked footage so in cinema if you go
to the layout up here you can you know
drop this down and go to the motion
tracker layout and you're presented with
some new buttons and everything and some
new panels and whatnot this is actually
really really handy there's a lot of
cool things and cool features that I
want to talk about so right over here to
the right double click to create a
motion tracker objects I'm just gonna
double click that and it creates this
motion tracker object up here with some
options down here so we could either
load our footage in manually or we could
just double click here to select the
footage once again so I'll do that
load the footage in and if we scrub you
can see we have all of every single
frame right it puts it together and
what's cool is like you can actually
navigate around this view because since
we're in 2d view up here we can navigate
around this view like you would in
cinema zooming in moving points and
stuff and if you hit H it'll snap it
back to full screen mode really really
handy so like I said we don't need to
track all this beginning stuff so let's
save ourselves some time here let's just
go to a frame 100 I'm a sure my sequence
frame 100 and
under the footage tab will start at
frame 100 and I don't know if we need to
go all the way like it kind of blurs out
here I can just call it it like frame
490 so we'll trim it there
we'll go frame 490 and that will be our
in-and-out
section there no down here you can see
that we can cache frames and everything
so it says three sixty four of six so
six frames cached if we hit play it'll
basically cache all of those frames for
you so that you can scrub through your
footage pretty easily now if you're
dealing with like 4k footage or even
five K footage and you're trying to
track that you can resample it so
resampling right now is set to 100
meaning it's not it's not down sampling
anything but if I said that's if I set
this to 50% it'll take my 720 by 1280
comp and it'll down the sample it to 360
by 640 but 100 is good for us right so
the next thing that we'll want to do
first off are you guys following here
well give me a little thumbs up if you
guys are following along I'm gonna crack
open one of these kombucha x' but yeah
the the c40 tracker is actually really
really cool I honestly hadn't used it
much before the see graph presentation
and it kind of forced me to learn it and
learn the ins and outs of it and there
are things I really like about it
sweet all right you guys good and I'm
gonna try and keep up with this chat as
best as possible you know I mean try and
focus on the lesson but at the same time
you know I'll keep my eye on the chat
and why do I drink so much kombucha dude
cuz it's good for you and I love the
flavor you know get as much ginger in
your system as possible it's good for
that healthy gut biome I don't know
that's that's that's what they say at
least I'm not a scientist I don't know
but I do try and keep keep my drinks and
my food as healthy as possible ok so we
have our footage loaded in right let's
go over to the 2g 2d tracking tab and
we're on the automatic tracking section
you can go to manual tracking and and
add all these manual points but we're
gonna stay on Auto track now this is
pretty much set up so that we can just
hit Auto track and it'll start doing its
thing and what's cool about the c4d
tracker is that it tracks forward and
backwards at the same time as you can
see by these two arrows you can track
backwards but you can track forwards but
you can also do both it'll kind of go
back and then back towards the center
point to ensure like the best possible
track you can up the number of tracks so
you can take this 300 I don't know we
can go to like 450 or something and
another another tip for you guys let's
say you have a shot we're like if it
starts here let's say it starts here and
then it moves out out of frame what's a
better example okay so maybe this this
shots probably not the best example but
if you have like let's say you're
panning across a landscape and you're
panning across certain features that you
that will never be seen again in that
frame like you're panning and you pass a
mountain the mountain passes frame left
and it never comes back basically like
you're gonna lose those tracking points
so what you want to do is like go
through your footage and you can hit
create auto tracks
that'll populate your scene with these
automatic trackers but it's just for
that little frame right there you know
and you're gonna want to go through and
just populate this with auto tracks you
can do that if you're afraid of like
losing certain tracking points
did you guys hear that did you guys hear
Gilbert getting meowing up a storm I'm
gonna undo that though I'm gonna undo
those tracks cuz we don't need them we
can just hit Auto track and it's gonna
work
so we upped our tracks from 300 to 450
so there's a couple more points that
it's it's looking at and I'm just gonna
hit Auto track and if you guys are ever
wondering if cinema4d is thinking or
lagging or is it working just look in
the bottom left down here and you'll see
it's processing these frames it's
counting up to four what are we at 490
and then it's going to count back down
and then back up again so it's just
scanning through all the all the frames
so yeah we're back in a c4d right now
I've been working on my Unreal Engine
I'd like to actually create a cool scene
with you guys next week so next week
we'll be back in Unreal Engine learning
the ins and outs or not the ins and outs
say it like I know the program will be
learning what I have learned so far I am
certainly not I'm not even at an
intermediate point in unreal engine I'm
still a beginner so but I still want to
jump in and share all my knowledge with
you guys because I really believe it is
the future so next week we'll be doing
Unreal Engine and trying to make a cool
scene with that
okay you guys can't see the footage when
you load it up maybe you need to
actually click the motion tracker maybe
that's what it is if you actually click
this but I haven't run into that problem
[Music]
so that's about as far as I can help you
with that
okay so you guys can see we have all of
these 2d tracks these are not 3d yet
there's still just 2d tracks and you can
see they have these little tails on them
but you can zoom in right and come
around here and and see their paths the
tail is the path and the actual diamond
is the tracking point now this can get a
little bit difficult to see so if I'm
gonna hit H and snap back to full frame
here okay and what you could do is go to
2d tracking and go to options okay and
in under options under display you can
change this track display to show tracks
and that's just gonna be the diamond
itself and this is still very difficult
for me to see so I'll go back to footage
and I'll take the brightness down to
like 25% and that way you can actually
see what the heck is going on with your
3d track
okay so now what we need to do is take
these 2d tracks and convert them into 3d
points so what we'll do here is we're
going to go to the 3d solve area and the
first time I did this you know I just
ran the 3d solver it's basically all you
need to do but it gave me some weird
focal lengths it was like 144 my focal
length and I know that's not the case
because I shot this on my iPhone so I
went to Google real quick and I just you
know googled the specs for the iPhone
focal lengths and it says the rear
camera is 28 millimeters so it's the 20
millimeter lens and that should mean
that if I type 28 right in the camera
settings
I changed focal length 10 to known
inconstant and I change the focal length
to 28 it should get a more accurate
representation or a more accurate track
if you actually know your focal length
if you shot it with like your DSLR or
something that's always really good info
to plug in to the 3d tracker because the
more oh goodness
Gilbert come on bud I don't even know
what view what what am I looking at here
God dang I don't even know what happened
guys what viewing my in
what just happened dude when you got
cats and keyboards man they do not go
well together jeez sabotage get worse
meowing cuz I don't know who knows why
this little buds meowing let's we
changed my view okay here we go
thanks Gilbert alright so yeah we need
to convert these into 3d points so we
got our focal length twenty millimeters
the more truths you can plug in to this
the better
and let's go ahead and just run the
solver and see what happens actually
real quick before we do that before we
do that if there are any 2d tracks that
are slipping and sliding around we'll
want to delete those because it's it's
basing our 3d solve off of these 2d
points and the more accurate these 2d
points are the better so I think what
I'm gonna do you see how the door is
moving here and all these points are
moving with the door I want to go ahead
and delete the points that are moving
with the door so I'm gonna wait until it
stops and then just delete all of these
points I'm gonna select all these points
and it'll repopulate you know these
points will certainly repopulate but I'm
gonna just go ahead and delete all of
these that move with this door and then
let's go to the moment before and just
make sure all those points are deleted
like this guy here and then you'll see
it starts to get it starts to repopulate
here which is great now this point here
you can see boom once you select a point
you get this window over here and you
can actually track it so it it certainly
has a mind of its own it starts moving
around after that point and it just kind
of goes off and disappears so we'll want
to delete that one - we don't want to
base our 3d track off of some janky 2d
points you know what I mean now you
don't have to do this
for everything because you know we'll be
here till next Christmas but if you just
do a quick scan of stuff like I'm seeing
these two points down here
those are floating I'll delete those
anything that starts floating you'll
want to go ahead and delete those and
I'm sure there's like a number that I'm
I'm missing here but you know we're
doing our best
all right I'm go ahead and save this
we'll be tracking and let's go ahead and
run our 3d solver with our focal length
plugged in and once again it's gonna be
thinking down on the bottom left down
here and it'll take a couple minutes in
the meantime if you guys got any
questions I am happy to answer
and what's cool about the cinema tracker
is that once you track your scene you're
gonna have to optimize it right so that
means the program wants to know which
way is up which way is left and right
which way is um you know which access is
the z-axis you basically need to tell
where's the y-axis where's the x and z
axis right so that knows where it is in
3d space and then you also need to tell
it the scale so it knows the scale of
say you know like this electrical outlet
mr. boku my favorite ice cream would
have to be coffee ice cream
it is quite delicious tracking in a
tracking NC forty is it better than
After Effects I'd say it has a lot more
options it has it way more options so
it's it's much more of a built out
tracker than than the After Effects
tracker the After Effects tracker is
good for like quick tracks and I'm I'm
wondering if the After Effects tracker
can track this I bet it can to be honest
with you and it's actually it's a little
bit more difficult to use simply because
it doesn't have that many features you
can't tweak that many things and
optimizing it or you know setting the
the correct orientation for your scene
is a bit more difficult and a bit more
like it's you're kind of you're kind of
putting a blindfold on and you're doing
it with a blindfold is the way it feels
but our 3d solve just finished let's
take a look at it
all right
so if I click off and then I scrub we
can see we have some points here green
points are good red points are not so
sure about themselves but the green
points are feeling a lot better okay so
this isn't bad but let's go ahead and
just see let's optimize this because as
you can see our grid view here is way
off if I were to spawn a cube like we're
inside the cube no good we want the
origin point not to be inside of our
camera but we want the origin point to
be sitting flush with this this outlet
here so I'm gonna go ahead and like I'll
leave this cube sitting here so you guys
can actually see what we're about to do
I'll hit the motion tracker and we'll go
ahead and save our scene and now that
it's been 3d solved you can you have a
couple more options down here actually
specifically this option right here the
Create position constraint and if you
hold that down you have three other
constraints or two others that you can
make but we'll start with position to
get our origin right so create position
constraint I have it selected you can
see we have a little constraint button
here and all we need to do is select one
of these 2d points that we want our to
be our origin so let's see let's have
this point right here be our origin and
if I click away you can see the cube has
been moved there but it's not oriented
properly but it is sitting at that spot
that's our origin now so 0 0 so if we
want to spawn like a person that person
is gonna be sitting right there right in
frame but again they're not oriented
properly so we need to adjust that real
quick before we move on I just want to
talk about this position constraint so
once we've created it you can see
there's little this little constraint
what would this be it's not a modifier
it's like a constraint tag
that has been created and the mode by
default the set feature to position the
feature is the 2d point we selected it's
this 2d point that's the feature and it
says feature to position and the
position is whatever we put in and in
this case by default it's set to 0 0 0
so that's the origin point now if we
hold this down we can make a vector
constraint as well and the vector
constraint is basically aligned so we
want to choose two points along the y
axis or the Z or the X and define which
axis that is so that our grid starts to
line up and starts to orient properly
and what's cool is because yeah cinema
has it all built in you don't have to do
it in another program it's all just in
one program so let's find points that
can be our like our y axis there's a lot
of points along this little bit here so
I'm gonna just select one and I'll
select two and it's kind of a trial and
error process we'll have to see if it
sticks but we have our y axis and a new
constraint tag was created and under the
axis box here we'll set that to Y and
now you can see our our grid just
aligned itself so I'm gonna scrub
through and make sure yep that looks
correct and I'll go to the end and it
actually that that looks correct all
right so if we click away we bring our
box back in we can see it starting to
get a little bit closer to the right
orientation so this is good now what
we'll do next up here is we need to set
another axis we need to set the z axis
or the x axis in this case I think the X
will work the best simply because
there's not much Z Z goes in into deep
space right Z will go will create depth
right but the X is like left and right
ok so we have that left and right data
that we need let's
select a motion tracker what would this
be the motion tracker object will select
that and we're gonna find some 2d points
that are along the x-axis like this one
and maybe maybe this one that's a little
off I'm gonna undo that so let's try
maybe zoom in here and see what's going
on I want to find two good points that
stick okay let's try this one and this
one and we'll say that is our x-axis and
let's see if it's stick so I'm gonna go
to the beginning it looks like see how
it's off a little bit right you can see
how that's off so that's no good and
then we'll go to the end and it it's
kind of still off so let's click away
just to see what our cube is doing and
it's not it's not bad but it's not the
best so let's try undoing that again
and let's see if we can't find another
two points that work for for us here
maybe these maybe these two let's try
that as X and I'll scrub to the
beginning that looks like it sticks and
I'll scrub to the end and it got off
again it got off again so that's no good
I want to undo that I'll try one more
and if one more doesn't work then I'll
do it manually and I'll show you guys
how how to do that so let's see here
all right let's find let's find some
points maybe like this one and this one
we'll set that as X
and we'll scrub and see if that works
looks like it looks like it's working in
the beginning and it looks like it kinda
is doing a thing at the end
that's not bad let's bring the cube back
in and I'm actually gonna flatten the
cube so we have a better representation
of like what this is actually doing and
how it's actually sitting here
all right that's not bad at all I think
it's the track is fine it just the
orientation I think needs to be tweaked
a little bit so what we'll do is I'm
gonna grab the motion tracker and I'm
going to put it inside of a null object
and I'm gonna rotate that null object so
that everything lines up perfectly so
I'm gonna hold alt and drop a null into
it by holding alt you make the motion
tracker a child of the null object and
let's go to coordinates and we'll just
rotate it along the x-axis like this
when it lines up looking nice and then
we can scrub through our footage and see
that it actually is sitting pretty nice
right inside of that a little electrical
socket now that 28 millimeter that I
typed in it might be a little extreme
just because like the iPhone I'm sure is
doing some cropping so it may be more
closer to like a I don't know a 30 or
something
it's hard to tell it's hard to say but I
think for our purposes this will be okay
this will this will totally work so yeah
well click away and let's hide these
auto features
awesome now let's just create no okay
here's another thing we have scale to
think about okay that that's a two meter
cube but at the same time like we are
creating a huge world we don't want our
huge world to be massive and to scale
because that'd just be ridiculous we
want to scale everything down so maybe
maybe what we'll do let's get rid of the
cube let's bring that person back in and
let's say how like how big do we want a
person to be in our small little CG
world here
mm yeah so you see how like the 28
millimeter lens is like these lines are
not are not correct so maybe what we'll
do is take this world and and just
adjust it a little bit like this and
we'll see if that does anything for us
yeah I mean like we could go back and
probably change the focal length of the
camera but I'm planning on actually
making this an exterior scene like it'd
be cool to do like a little construction
yard or something so I'm gonna roll with
this since we don't have all the time in
the world but I think you guys get the
idea now let's go back to our idea of
scale here so I'm gonna go back to our
motion tracker I'm gonna select any one
of our position or any one of our vector
constraints and in this case the x-axis
all right for length we'll say we know
it even though we don't and that
actually by default snaps to more of a
size that I feel like is gonna work for
our our little world here so if I go to
filter and I turn off work plane grid
and let's bring in the wireframe mode
you can see the little person sitting
there and we'll say a person is gonna be
about that size in this in this world
right because I want to put down like a
layer of dirt and then have like a fake
sky and maybe put like a little
construction truck in there or something
and just building out like a small
little playground all right so next we
should probably build out like the tiny
little box that we're going to be
putting our world in okay so on the
origin I'm going to spawn a plane and
let's go ahead and rotate it holding
shift to snap it to 90 degrees here and
I just want to bring it out so that it's
fitting the bounds here of our of our
electrical outlet
I see that doesn't work that doesn't
work for us you see the the focal length
is off so I'm actually gonna I'm gonna
redo it I'm gonna go back and let's try
this one more time let's keep all those
things that's fine the 2d tracking is OK
3d tracking let's try changing the focal
length to let's try a 35 okay or in fact
let's just try 36 by default and let's
try running the solver and see what
happens
so in the bottom-left it's doing its
thing it's thinking real hard
when sometimes it's tough working with
the iPhone sometimes it skips frames
there's like variable shutter speed so
it's tough with motion blur and random
nation weird motion tracking a shot
right now inside of cinema 4d 3d
tracking it actually and we're trying to
just refine our track here so that it
better matches our scene so that we can
move forward and and add our CG elements
to our 3d scene and make it look legit
and mix with this 2d footage as well
Birk a I'm glad that you could still
join even though you're still at work it
means a lot thank you so much
I hope works going okay for you I know
it's kind of tough some people actually
really enjoy working from home I'm I'm
definitely in that boat
so going back to work can be tough but
hey at least we're at least we have a
job you know at least we're getting
closer to making ends meet and
everything and I hope that you're doing
all right
yeah how do you know the mobile camera
focal length here like okay so made our
scene let's move forward and see here
let's see if if this is working okay
let's take these constraints and let's
go ahead and delete the constraints or
didn't even need to do that let me I
mean maybe I didn't need to delete the
constraints and let's take the null and
I'm just gonna zero it out and let's
bring in that cube and see or the plane
rather and it it's hard to tell like did
it did it get closer
yeah this is a this is a tough one so
let's let's give after-effects tracker a
spin and let's see if if this works
let's go to frame 100 and let's just
throw down let's let's go
3d tracker and this is why I always like
I always like doing multiple multiple
trackers trying different methods
because sometimes other ones work by
default when others require a lot more
like manual labor to get you know a nice
little like a track out of it right so
this is gonna go here it looks like it's
gonna track the entire thing but it
shouldn't take long it's just gonna take
a minute but I think the thing that's
holding us back is the focal length so
if um so I have an iPhone X R let's just
Google iPhone X our focal length and it
says 28 millimeters let's see if we can
find like if there's a difference
between like the camera and the video
camera because I know the video camera
like zooms in
yeah it says 28 millimeter equivalent
I mean 28:28 seems right to me
sensor size let's try the sensor size in
the iPhone iPhone XR sensor size
hmm ass tough one
I'm not really sure maybe let's try it
let's try changing it back to let's see
go back to the tracker and let's change
this to unknown and we'll run the solver
again and we'll go back to FX and we can
see we have all these points wonderful
yes look the after fixed tracker worked
now let's just see if this lines up okay
let's do let's make our tracker tracking
point smaller subtract point size will
go like 25 okay and I want to find four
points that that meet the corner
so maybe like this one one two I'm
holding shift three and four I'm gonna
right-click will set ground plane and
origin and I'm going to right-click
again and create a null or no I'm sorry
I'm gonna create a solid and now we have
a solid sitting there that actually
looks nice
so let's orient this properly we want Y
pointing up and Z pointing away alright
so let's see here let's go let's orient
this properly there we go like that and
let's go ahead and like let's go ahead
and scale this I'm gonna unlink it I'm
gonna scale it on the Y and you can see
here how like the after effects tracker
it really it can come in handy because
now that actually matches the aspect
ratio and the focal length of this box
you know the perspective of the box and
let's go ahead and scale it on the X as
well so we know that's kind of the area
we want to deal with there and this is
this is After Effects tracker by default
this is great so this is basically like
our floor plane it's gonna be obviously
90 degrees rotated from there but I'm
gonna name this floor and I'll show you
guys how i optimize my scene so that I
can bring it inside of cinema 4d and the
the dimensions are gonna stay the same
so with the floor selected let's go
ahead and parent the camera to the floor
okay is that right
that should be right mm-hmm maybe the
scale needs to come back down because we
know that was like a test right so we
know it works
let's parent the camera to the floor
there we go okay so we want to normalize
our scene
first we'll normalize the rotation so if
we go our we'll just zero everything out
besides this X input which is at 270 the
position needs to be since this is what
this is 720 by 1280 so we needed to do
that by half so 720 divided by 2 should
be 360 and then 1280 divided by 2 is 640
and then zero out the last little number
so that is going to bring that's setting
our origin point so that it's at 0-0
when we get to cinema and then finally
it's and again just a touch on that it's
half of your composition resolution so
the our comp is 720 by 1280 so we're
setting the position to 360 by 640 and
then the last thing we want to check is
scale so it's right now it's set to 100
let's go ahead and hit control Y we'll
make a new solid I'll make it okay yeah
I'll make it a 3d layer we can see that
our rotation is off we want it to stand
up tall so let's go to rotation and
adjust that rotation so it just zeros
out okay and then let's go ahead and
scale our floor down until this black
solid kind of matches and fits into our
composition so let's try this and about
like there
feels pretty good to me all right so now
our scene is optimized we can delete
this black solid and we can unparent
from the floor and when we bring this in
cinema everything should be lined up
pretty nice alright so we want to go
file export max on cinema 4d exporter
and I'm just gonna find a spot for this
real quick all right back inside of
cinema and it actually looks like yeah
that's cool it actually looks like the
default numbers worked for us because
now our plane actually lines up so we
didn't even have to do that in After
Effects but I showed you guys you can do
both that looks really nice
yeah that actually lines up sweet much
better much much better I'm gonna hop
out of the tracker layout I'm just gonna
go back to standard ya scrub through
here and let's give this plane zero
segments and it should be sitting yep on
0 for the Z okay so it's sitting right
on the face of our of our electrical
outlet and real quick just so I can show
you guys what the After Effects scene
looks like I'm gonna go ahead and open
that up for you and we'll load in our
footage I'm going to double click make a
new material down here and let's go
ahead and load our JPEG sequence we'll
click it we'll go to animation and
calculate if you port animate preview
all right and then I'm gonna hold this
down make a background drop it into the
background and notice our scene is
optimized and set up in a way that
allows us to just hop in and get going
inside of cinema so either either way is
gonna work for us here whether it's the
after-effects tracker or the c4d tracker
so that was cool I wasn't expecting to
to ace both of them but the c40 tracker
took a little bit more work the
after-effects tracker was a bit more of
an automated process sometimes the
after-effects tracker just doesn't work
and the c4d tracker is way better it
really depends on the shot all right um
let's see
all right so moving on let's deal with
let's make that let's make that box
because we want to have a little box to
set our world inside of yeah that feels
good to me okay so let's take this plane
and once you have it matched up to the
dimensions of your box I'm gonna scale
it down just a little bit probably right
here and let's hop out of our camera
view and I'm gonna hide these tracked
features and we'll select the back of
this plane I'm gonna make it editable
I'll select the back of the plane hmm
let's reverse our normals we want to
make sure that what we're facing is
orange versus blue so let's see reversed
normals you are would be the shortcut
and I'm gonna select all of these edges
ctrl a ctrl drag click and drag and that
will just create a little box for us
moving back into the wall and I'll
select that front plane and I'll delete
it and we'll want to close the polygon
hole in the back so that's gonna be MD
boom closed polygon hole and let's make
sure our normals are set and they need
to be reversed you are I think it was
yes so now what we have when we hop in
here is we we actually have a box that
kind of has some depth to it and it
moved its it actually like sits a little
deeper in 3d space so we can set our
scene here we can build out any sort of
room or world we want and and then we
just need to light it in a way that that
feels natural so I'm gonna actually push
this plane back a little bit more right
so we have a bit more depth in parallax
in our scene so we're coming around and
like getting the full view
that so that's gonna be that's gonna be
really cool
okay you guys falling along so far let's
feel okay to you guys we talked about
the after-effects tracker we talked
about the cinema4d tracker and using
them both to get a solid track out of
this so now we just need to figure out
what goes in this box and obviously we
need to light it so I think what we'll
do next is probably figure out what goes
inside of the box and I'm actually going
to ask you guys what do you guys want to
see inside of this thing go easy on me I
don't have all day but I think we can
make a small little like diorama inside
of this we could do maybe like an
outdoor construction site now like a
room with a whole bunch of stuff in it
it's probably a bit too much work but we
could we could maybe do a beach scene
like a pool or something we could do a
forest maybe a four little forest scene
with some trees inside hmmm
it'd actually be really cool to
photoscan an environment and put that in
the side of their that would be sweet Oh
a fish tank fish tank will be cool Park
okay a space Beach beach
hmm mega scan Z I'll probably be using a
lot of mega scans forests mmm okay
forest maybe we'll do something like
that we'll do a little forest scene or
something
what could the background be because if
it's like a little room a little box
room oh we could also do so we could
also push we could also push this back a
little bit more and do let's see if I
hit KL it'll be a loop path cut and I
hold shift we can like snap to the
middle and we'll grab this little bit
we'll control drag it that way so it
turns a corner like that right
that's interesting
huh
maybe it's like a metro
or like a train station
with a big window like right here like a
stained-glass window shining down or
something and we have some park benches
maybe or it's like a clock or it's just
straight up shoot okay just the metro
line it could it could it could do
something cool where we grab these
points are these faces rather
and we can extrude inner MW and we'll
drop let's see we'll drop this down Mt
so that's gonna be like the trip the
train tracks and then maybe on the other
side here is the other the other
platform or something just push that
back a little bit and then you could
have like a little like a little
escalator going up or something right
here so push that back in space and then
they'll be like a little escalator going
up that way
okay I think that's pretty cool I think
that could be really fun and they'll be
like struts along the wall or something
alright so now we're at the point we're
like let's see alright
I'm just getting a whole bunch of ideas
here I'm gonna take these points let's
move them now let's do let's hop out of
the camera
and just move that back a little bit so
there's a bit more room to stand there
sweet
let's grab these points I'm just gonna
try and make more of like a platformer
in here
yeah this is gonna be cool awesome all
right I'm glad this is giving you guys
some good ideas I'm excited about this
alex says turn on back face culling what
is that I've heard about it but I don't
know what it is is it a bit easier
an easier way for you guys to view
what's going on maybe some ambient
occlusion would help let's see where is
my ambient occlusion settings filter
effects here we go
radius 20 let's just boost it up it's
kind of janky
okay here we go
oh snap that's a good one
and see
backface NP that's good
okay that's good very nice
thank you for that tip that's a good one
very good one okay so we're kind of set
up to start detailing out this thing
then we can talk about lighting later so
I'm gonna need to gather some assets and
probably some reference footage so let's
just look up let's Google metro station
or Japanese train station something
something like this that's cool it has
the ads on the wall like we can do so
much detail on this you know it has the
the pillars these standing pillars that
we can put in here so let's see let's
get our like let's get our our scale
right yeah that that feels good to me
you know there's a person there let's go
and move this person down to this ground
plane so we want the person to fit right
on the ground there so let's go ahead
and just eyeball this in I'm hating s to
snap my vport to the objects selected
okay that's great now is there a way I
want to have my origin point be right on
the ground here so how would I do how
would I do that let's let's think about
this for a second
there we go I think if I just move it no
actually I doesn't work
esker it well we'll just hold ctrl and
will spawn things on this person that's
what we'll do
all right what does the ceiling look
like okay it's a very low ceiling but I
think ours will be a high ceiling so we
need an actual metro line we need this
floor pattern this multiple floor
pattern we need the tracks which I know
mega scans has the tracks so I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna go to bridge and
start favoriting some items here that I
know I'm gonna need okay so this is
quick sabrage you guys don't know about
it it's basically the best thing ever
and it allows us to transfer all of the
any mega scans library asset we want
we're gonna go ahead and transfer that
into any program of our choice so you
see right here train tracks these are
some like old train tracks but I think
this would actually work
these railway tracks right here
yeah these are definitely older but I
think that's okay I'm gonna head and
favorite this let's see what they have
for concrete barriers
maybe something like something like this
could be a useful item I know we want
let's see if we go home we'll go to
services and let's just type in I know
they have that like crosswalk texture
what is it called it's a floor some type
let's see that's that crosswalk that
yellow crosswalk kind of texture I know
that polygon has one but I think mega
scans does too um crosswalk what would
that be called yellow crosswalk surface
it's like the bumpy the bumpy surface
hmm let's check polygons
I know they have it let's do man-made
or is it under doesn't have a floor
let's eat crosswalk dang I know he has
it yeah the thing for blind people yeah
oh it's not in surfaces I got you
let's just search everything
tactile paving
ah here it is yes it's a decal yeah all
right nice find
we'll grab this one too we'll get both
heck we'll do all three good fine thank
you guys thank you thank you
Surya appreciate you okay um let's let's
go back to our reference let's go back
to a reference and see what we need okay
did I close it I may have closed it
oh yeah this is good so we have these
like top lights and we have these signs
and stuff and there's a lot of like
detail on the ground so there's like
this beige tile that we can use
so let's find surfaces ground
maybe it's under tile ceramic ooh this
is good something like this we can we
can scale this up that's nice I like
that this is good anti-slip we'll grab
that so yeah I just gonna wanna go
through here and like pick your
materials and everything and this is
gonna probably be the longest portion of
the process is piecing everything
together let's see what the walls look
like so hmm yeah there's a lot of detail
in this there's all these ads you know
so we can go to town on the banners and
stuff well here's a here's a look
there's a nice one yeah we have all
these signs and everything and these
pillars
so maybe this needs to be like a let me
save this actually and I'm just saving
iterations so I can always go back if I
need to I'll hop out of camera view and
I want to make sure like let's let's get
to maybe there's two areas for where the
actual train is going through so we want
we want to fit two trains in here I'll
go back to the plane and let's just move
everything
mandus back face culling is so nice
let's move everything all these points
back a little bit more so that way it's
creating like we have two sections now
where the Train is going to be passing
and I'm gonna make sure
that we don't see the edges alright the
train just keeps going so let's do let's
move these points back
like that okay
a little bit further and very nice man
yeah you can really go to town on this
yep chips we're doing a secret diorama
of a metro station exactly okay so let's
just like let's block this in a little
bit more we can throw some pillars down
and I'm actually I'll probably to make
this this little waiting area a little
larger
I'll give it a bit more room so maybe we
just keep adding depth to it the more
depth to this little secret diorama the
better so let's do let's grab these
points and push them back
awesome
sweet okay let's let's see what else we
need so the only reason I'm like
hesitant to do these pillars and these
arches is just because like maybe they
just go to the ceiling I guess I think
that could be fine but it might it might
feel a little weird but let's let's see
so I'll make a cylinder and I'll
actually spawn the cylinder on the
figure so if you have the figure
selected I'll hold control and make a
cylinder and now that cylinder is
spawned inside of that person or in the
place of the object you had selected so
let's go ahead and scale this up so we
have these two pillars
I don't know I feel about these
yeah I don't know maybe maybe I'll get
rid of the cylinders I think this is
gonna be cool you know just this Michael
that's awesome
I'm glad you pieced piece that together
round
okay so let's see about texturing this
this thing out okay we want to have a
metro going through here a Japanese like
little metro some junior line or
something this one right here so let's
do a search let's see okay let's try
turbosquid
and we'll search for free well we'll see
we can find here hmm
okay not not much this doesn't do is
much here um I mean I'm down to pay for
five bucks I can pay five bucks for
something
let me try CG trader you guys tell me
about this website it's actually really
nice
hey Arnie thanks for the super chat
appreciate you man thank you thank you
thank you it really helps out a lot
you know these tutorials they take a lot
to to get started there's a lot of
pre-work I got to put in and even after
the fact I still have to keep working on
it to put out that final result so the
super chats really really helped and I
really appreciate your support so Arnie
thank you thank you a ton heck yeah
Independence Day stream okay let's let's
see what we can find on CD trader do
they have any like metro trains Metro
train
see I can just buy this scene for a
hundred bucks and pop it in do they have
anything for free this isn't bad here no
that's pretty bad that's pretty bad
let's see what they got for 10 bucks
all right
four dollars for this train here that's
not bad
ooh $8.00 this is it this is about it
right here
FBX yes okay I'm gonna get this this is
a good one
give me one second guys while I go ahead
and log in and get this train asset
going if you guys can think of any of
any other things I'll need for this
little metro let me know in the chat
while I download this
alright almost done here guys
gathering assets this is like this is
the longest part of the process
man come on started leave you hanging
guys just bear with me here
okay I think we're in business we got
the FBX ready to go
what on earth there it is
sweet very cool
all right so the axis is all off I also
that also has some key frames that I
want to delete let's go ahead and zero
out all this stuff here
and I'll use the exes Center tool to
Center the axes up with the model
perfect and I'm actually gonna bring it
all the way down to the Y so it's
sitting right at the bottom that way I
can you know get this train to sit on
the ground okay let's take the train
bring it into our scene okay boom it's
tiny we'll scale this thing up
and how does this work okay so trains I
guess yeah they're like the doors are
right on the edge so let's hop in here
so that the door comes right up to the
edge of this thing
it looks I can't tell this kind of janky
I'm go and delete all these train
materials
and we'll get that right there on the
edge
I'm just lining the train up
there we go
and then we have a second train
going the other direction so I'll copy
that and move that over here and we'll
rotate that around and bring up these
polygons so that like so it's just
enough to like fit fit these two trains
right I think you guys get the idea you
know we're going to be building this
thing out for the next hour or so let's
bring these points in and bring these
points up
awesome
and let's start texturing this thing and
start throwing down some textures all
right so this is definitely one we're
like the more time you spend on this the
better it's gonna be and the more detail
you add the better so I think what we'll
do is we'll actually make a shadow
catcher material in octane and apply it
to all these front faces so like here
and here
and then let's load in our JPEG sequence
and we'll go to our octane settings and
just make sure that alpha channel is
checked
keep environment is unchecked will hop
back into the camera
all right
so when we render this we we don't want
to see any of this any of these top
faces or any of these side faces we just
want to see what's on the inside so we
might have to do that and like render
passes and stuff and maybe what I'll do
for for this tutorial is just kind of
give you guys I may not go super deep
into the texturing and everything and
the placement of assets but I'll at
least well at least render something out
we'll light it so it looks nice so I'm
gonna drop in an HDRI image just so it
you know the lighting is a bit more
uniform between our live-action plate
and the CG elements here and let's go
and delete that
that shadow catcher we don't need that
for a second I'm gonna make a new octane
sky and I'm going to load in a custom
HDRI image that I took
all right so this is actually taken
basically right where the camera is I'm
going to scale up this sphere and let's
hide the plane for a second and we'll
hide the trains let's go and organize
this
so we'll just group that alt G I'm gonna
call this geo for geometry and then I
like to let's see let's do the figure
and the background the octane sky and
this sphere I'll do that and I'll call
that scene and the null that's our
camera so in the scene let's take let's
make a new octane glossy material drag
and drop it onto the sphere here and
let's go ahead and let's see let's go to
index drop it down to one and let's go
ahead and just give this sphere a bit
more segments
all right and let's just make sure that
this thing is oriented properly so let's
go to switch over to DL and I'm going to
select the octane sky tag go into node
view
let's give it a color corrector color
correction node okay and then I'm going
to give it a transform node that way we
can move this hgri around to about there
because that's where we filmed this
thing from back in the path tracing and
I think hmmm it might be I might just
leave about a fault I think it looks
fine by default
let's hide this fear and let's bring our
geometry back in
and let's try and set up that flat wall
plane as a frontal projection or with
frontal projection that Alex is talking
about I think that's probably the best
way to do this so I'm wondering if we
can take certain parts of this plane
here like these bits and even this even
all these top faces too so everything up
here everything facing the camera
basically everything back there and
these bits on the side
maybe we'll start with we'll start with
these and we'll see if we can get
projection working so let's try let's
see let's drag and drop our footage onto
just those polygons and it's giving me
it's saying I can't do it let me set
selection and we'll try this way okay
and then now what we need to do is go to
projection I believe camera mapping is
the way to do this front we'll set that
the front and we'll select our camera
will drop our camera right in there and
it never works exactly as I needed to so
standard it's looking for an aspect
ratio 16:9
so it's like one let's see 16 by 9 so 9
by 16 because we're vertical man that's
not working well we can calculate it but
you see how it's all broken up and it
looks it needs to probably be in the
luminance channel so let's let's copy
this paste nope
paste in luminance that ways maintaining
his full brightness
maybe we need to convert this to an
octane material
shoot having trouble here
hmm
I don't know why it's not just playing
properly hmm man it's all
troubleshooting guys the effects lots of
troubleshooting lots of googling things
you don't know yeah I feel like octane
does have a camera projection note I'm
just not familiar with it too much I
don't use it too much let's see let's
load our sequence again
see about getting some lights in here so
going back to the reference we can see
that there's these strip lights all
across the top all across the ceiling
here so maybe we can do something
similar by maybe up on the ceiling here
we can add some some octane area lights
let's go ahead and like move this down
rotate 90
and we'll just get this out
so one will just be on one side of the
track
we'll go up to the ceiling and then the
other will just be on the other side of
the track
and we'll take both of those and we'll
just bring the power down to like 25 or
something and let's change the the tent
like they're kind of I feel like they're
they're like those uh
that greenish tint you know that
tungsten or not tungsten but um I forget
the term the fluorescent bulbs are those
fluorescent bulbs they're just a little
green which i think is pretty pretty
cool it's a pretty cool look so maybe we
can take the texture and give it a see
4d RGB spectrum and we'll just make it a
little bit on the green side so you get
that just that nice little tint okay so
we can also drop in our bridge assets
that we downloaded like the floor and
the tiling and all that stuff so let's
go ahead and export these we'll go to
our favorites and we want to export all
this stuff for cinema 4d so we want to
make sure that stuff is all properly set
up okay we want to download all this you
can select all those at once and we can
download all six assets
while that downloads let's try and work
on this projection bit so yeah I think
that's a good idea who said it David
yeah let's try let's try that David I'm
gonna select the edges of this plane
here yep
ul for a loop selection and let's just
go ahead and go to our scale tool I'm
gonna hold ctrl and drag and that's
gonna make new polygons right there for
us and then we'll scale it along this
side we'll scale it up so it's just in
covering our entire scene like this I'll
hop back into camera to make sure we're
covering everything now we're getting in
there now this is also a really cool tip
to that you guys can use your actual
tracked data from your tracked camera
and make a full CG scene that way so
like we can build this whole thing out
right obviously you can tell here in the
render that this is entirely CG now and
it can feel interesting because it was
shot with a real camera but you tricked
the audience and you actually build out
a full CG environment using that actual
tracked camera data it can give it a
really cool look and feel so let's see
let's take these four polygons let's
turn off these lights for a second let's
grab all this and we'll make this let's
see maybe this is the shadow catcher
or we can set that selection there we go
that is actually working for us do you
see in the render here we are we're
getting exactly what we want and only
what we want so David thank you that was
actually the best way to go about that
and we're peering inside of this let's
turn those lights back on they really
helped that's awesome
all right
let's bring these lights up just a
little bit more
sweet so how did I get the backplate to
show up in the render basically I went
to my octane settings and I set that to
alpha channel and I unchecked to keep
environment so that's gonna actually
allow the backplate to show through your
footage down here and I man I'm in path
tracing indirect lighting you know
you're gonna have to go back to octane
and change those settings again if you
want that indirect lighting as well but
direct lighting actually keeps that
green tint but yeah Pat raising is
probably what we want for this situation
because we've got a lot of bounce light
bouncing all around in here
I think these trains need to be scaled
up so I'm gonna take both of those
trains I'm gonna scale these things up
and just make sure it's looking nice
from our side view I'm turn off these
lights so it's a little easier to see
and it'll take these two trains
and it's a little hard to see so I'm
gonna hide the background
that feels right
sweet
all right so let's let's add that tiling
back to bridge we can see a list all of
our stuff is downloaded for the most
part no I guess it's still downloading
did it stop here weird well we have our
dirty swimming pool texture so let's
start with that export settings we want
to make sure we're going to cinema 4d
not Unreal Engine and what export 4k is
fine and let's go ahead this is done as
well and we'll just transfer all these
that are finished
so we probably not even gonna need the
train tracks because we don't even see
them
are you guys doing okay lag too bad for
you guys I think I just want to download
one more thing here this this yellow
tiling
and we'll export so man I I realize like
you could spend a week on this adding
vending machines and signs and lights
and everything and really building it
out to to be a full and complete scene
and there's just no way I'm gonna be
able to max this thing out on the stream
here just why I just I wish I had more
more time you know to set this kind of
stuff up so it'd be nice to actually
like have the completed version for you
guys and then just kind of break it down
live okay so we have our stuff imported
in here let's go ahead and start
applying it so let's start with the
actual the floor tile all right let's
see let's see
all right so I'm gonna render region
here just so we can actually see what's
going a little bit better and let's go
ahead and drop our that swimming pool
texture on to the floor
all right so the mapping is way off with
the wrapping rather is way off so let's
go into the node editor and fix that up
the easiest way to do that or you know
what honestly it's probably easiest to
do it up here let's select the
projection UV mapping and we'll set that
to let's try flat
cool so that actually worked for us and
then we want to scale it way up so let's
go tiles
point to refresh our scene and scorn
thank you sir for the super chat much
appreciated
I'm glad you enjoy them and I'm glad
that you can actually you know learn a
thing or two from these I know they're
not as like direct and full of
information as a produced tutorial would
be but I still think it's fun to do this
okay so we have our tiles but the tile
ends right there we wanted to end we
want to scoot it back a little bit so
let's take the offset V I believe let's
set it to one and see what happens it's
just annoying that the rear end of this
every time try setting it to two point
five maybe I can't tell that to doing
anything
[Music]
yeah I cannot tell
here we go we can actually see it in our
viewport and yes that makes more sense
I'm just lining it up so the tiles make
sense let's try point one 0.16 0.16
perfect
I know I need more GPUs guys I'm still
in a 1070 it's crazy it's crazy but
hopefully there'll be something cool for
all of us in the works here so we'll see
about that
and I'm glad you guys prefer the live
streams over the the full tutorial but I
got a couple of those in the works for
you guys as well let's add this yellow
bit so I'll select those three and let's
go ahead and drag and drop this yellow
texture let's make sure our selection is
right so we just want these three little
strips and we'll go to this little bit
and we'll hit set selection all right
and we're not seeing anything I don't
know why yet
it has opacity with it okay so if I got
rid of this opacity then it's coming in
okay now let's go back and we'll change
this to flat and now we're actually
seeing the material awesome all right so
let's adjust this so it actually lines
up
we wanna make it large enough so that
one of these fits inside so it's kind of
trial and error here there we go that
that works
it feels like it's stretched needs to be
stretched on there we go
and let's give it let's try 0.8 and 1.6
something like that
that works for the most part let's get
some texture on the actual wall here on
the this may be some sort of tile or
reflective tile as well oh it's like a
brick material let's try that let's try
a brick material so in bridge I'm going
to go to surfaces let's find tile stone
sidewalk ceramic and we'll see we can
find like a brick ceramic brick texture
Tokio wall tiles that's not bad
maybe something like this let's give
this one a shot
let's try downloading this guy
yeah I'd be putting vending machines in
here signs on the wall like posters and
stuff let's try let's try adding like a
cube and I'm just gonna like flatten it
out scale it up and we can put
advertisements on this
but maybe next time I'm in the subway
I'll just photoscan it so I can just
drop it in and it'll be a lot easier so
we can put ads on on the walls here
let's just try googling like like
Japanese boss coffee billboard and we
could like take one of these or
something and rework it
like like this right here you know we
can take this save this image out
and we can drop that let's see if I make
a new octane glossy material we can drop
that on these cubes and then we can load
in the diffuse channel we can load up
that image we just saved
you
you guys can see why this is taking a
really long time to get the feeling
right you know because there's just a
lot of details you'd want to add to
build out this whole scene you know and
you can give each one of these like a
little light panel above it shining down
let's go back to bridge and see what's
good with our our tile texture so we'll
bring this into cinema
yeah definitely a wet floor would be Oh
a wet floor sign yes that'd be very nice
maybe there's some assets in bridge mmm
caution 3d assets construction Street
so you could definitely add a whole
bunch of this stuff I think like some of
these caution caution cones or something
will be sweet you know I have this one I
could bring this one in
and now let's get let's let's adjust our
actual wall texture cool drag-and-drop
and the material wrapping is insane so
let's go back here let's set it to cubic
and we'll scale it up a little bit so
we'll try tiling 0.5 and I want to
brighten up this this diffuse pass just
a little bit so I'll take the brightness
we'll go to two maybe three it
definitely feels gross it definitely
feels like a gross like metro and not in
a good way it's gonna take a lot of work
to actually get this to look right
denne um tips for unwrapping UVs man I
to be honest with you I do not have many
tips on unwrapping you've ease it is not
my specialty and it is certainly an area
I need to put more time and effort into
though I do know that in cinema 4d r22
there's like a whole new unwrapping
feature and on in unwrapping kind of
layouts so they make it a lot easier in
c4d r22 that's all I know though it's
about all I know 3d model Haven has one
oh yes that's right that's right
3d model Haven com
here we go wet floor this is great we
get the FBX oh they have high poly
versions now - awesome might as well
yeah
3d model Haven is such a great site it's
part of the texture Haven and hgri Haven
kind of like conglomerate and it's very
very useful very high quality stuff some
of the highest quality stuff let's see
where do we want to put this
alright and we'll download the textures
alright back in the cinema I'll just
make a new it's actually yeah let's
merge it with the model we just
downloaded the wet floor sign we'll get
that FBX loaded in and then I'm just
gonna go ahead and like solo this thing
so I'm gonna click select the sign and
we'll solo it and we'll hop in I'll make
a new glossy material drag and drop and
let's go ahead and drop in all of our
assets so actually I'll make a new RGB
or now an image texture that's what I
want okay and I'm going to load these
textures that we just downloaded
all right so that's what the diffuse and
it's not wrapping properly why is that
strange
so weird
Wow me geez maybe it needs to be flipped
or something let's try adding a
transform node and flipping at rotation
180 on one of these axes
what is going on
man I do not know
this is what it's supposed to look like
maybe I imported it weird
yeah the 8-bit ones not working either
that's strange
huh
yeah the low-poly model maybe
all right geometry yeah that's fine
animation now materials should be good
how the low-poly one works that's weird
that's really weird anyway that should
be fine for us now we have a nice little
wet floor sign that we can add in
alright I'll get out of solo view and we
want to transform this sign to this
figure that way it's on the ground it's
same for the construction cone we can
take this thing and let's move the gizmo
to the bottom and then we'll transform
it once again we'll transform it to the
wet floor sign that's totally fine we
can scale it up
and we'll just put a couple in here
awesome sweet
and the train itself like I don't think
we're gonna have time to texture this
thing but maybe what we can do in the
meantime is just give it some like
emissive materials in the window so we
can grab in our train if we're lucky
enough will actually have the windows as
its own geometry that way we can easily
just drag and drop
so let's do
[Music]
yeah it looks like this is all one piece
so we'll have to go in and grab these
window bits
and I'm wondering if any one of these
set selection tags are just the windows
and I'm hoping that's the case yeah
there we go
so that's Windows I'll make a diffuse
material drop it on there and we'll give
it an emission blackbody emission
let's unsolo hop back in render our
scene and see what it looks like
it's probably gonna be really intense
but I guess that's not the case let's go
to our mission settings and check
surface brightness that that will do the
trick
cool
and just for the heck of it let's let's
give the the train a chrome material or
a scratched metal or something so we
actually have that chrome here
and we'll throw it down on the train
it looks like that's not doing anything
alright let's see let's find it looks
like applying the chrome material to
just the train isn't working because I
think I need to delete all these
question marks because it's still I
think it's still trying to like find the
original textures which I deleted
because they were whoa that is intense
what is happening there
okay by making it Chrome by making the
whole thing chrome it like blows out
everything that's weird
Oh weird okay it's working for
everything but I see I see
all right so obviously there is a ton
more work to do on texturing this and
building out this metro station but I
think I'm gonna render this I'm gonna
render a little bit of frame so we can
see what it looks like in after-effects
and we can composite in after-effects so
let's let me just tweak this chrome real
quick I'm gonna give it some roughness
so does like point two and I don't know
why the rest of oh it's because of these
question marks again so bear with me
while I get rid of all this stuff
there we go okay so now it should
actually be working on both trains
awesome and I was going to animate these
things real quick
so we'll start with one train speeding
by so as soon as we open it this is
gonna be speeding by
starting from like here we'll make a
keyframe we'll move forward and we'll
move this train all the way across the
train tracks to like there where it's
gone out of view we'll make a new
keyframe I'm will hold shift f3 shift f3
and that will bring up our timeline here
and I'm going to select both of those
points and just set them to linear
and another trick that I actually
learned from Andre Libre Andre Libre I
think that's his name he has a great
YouTube channel but he actually just
recently dropped a c4d like tips and
tricks video and one of them was really
cool where if you hit play and you're
not getting your full frame rate which
it looks like here we definitely are
we're getting 33 40 frames a second what
you can do is hold down this film strip
and uncheck all frames and it's going to
play out your animation or play your
sequence in real time it may still be
laggy and chunky but it'll it will
essentially ensure that you'll you'll be
able to watch through your sequence and
as real of like feedback as possible so
we can have that train move a lot faster
awesome and then this this first train
will just kind of like move into the
station
and maybe what we'll do is for will
actually scoot this back so the train
passes and then this other train starts
pulling up
so we'll do like a keyframe here and
we'll move forward and have the train
stop like right right here at the end
we'll make another keyframe this first
keyframe will set to a linear keyframe
and the second one we're going to
actually animate and tweak a little bit
in the animation window so we want the
x-axis so if we open this up and we go
to position x axis you can see how it's
just kind of like a linear line we want
it to slow come to a really slow stop so
I can select both of these keyframes
here and I'm pretty sure yeah it's just
the X just like both of those and we'll
give them like a Bezier curve and this
one wants to basically start as a linear
keyframe so I'm gonna get that just
right in there and this one wants to
slow down to a stop so something like
this right so it curves up and it slowly
comes to that stop right so let's see
what that looks like
so it rushes in and then comes to that
nice slow stop but I think it's a little
it comes in a little fast something like
that that's cool and let's hop into our
camera to make sure we're only seeing
what we want to see here let's bring its
back over so we can see our viewport a
little bit better and let's play it so
you see how that train is hiding right
there we want to bring this train back a
little bit when it starts out so we'll
push this back a little bit more make a
keyframe there and really condense these
keyframes so that thing flies by and we
get in here and then this train comes in
you know and then you'll animate the
scene further but we could let's get rid
of this figure real quick you can
populate this with a whole bunch of
people and go to town with it
but again just for the sake of time we
don't have much of it cuz it's the 4th
of July baby I got barbecues to go to ok
so I'm actually gonna render this out
with motion blur and to do that at least
as far as octane goes you'll want to go
to your camera and make sure it has an
octane tag on it you can right-click it
go to c42
octane tags and give it an octane camera
tag and under motion blur I'm gonna just
set this to like 1 over 60 ok
and we'll make sure our shutter
alignment is centered and we will enable
it and it looks like energy geometry
will give the train an octane object tag
and that just kind of like allows the
camera to talk with these objects
specifically
and it's gonna say hey we see that
you're moving real fast we're gonna give
you some motion blur so I'll show you
what that looks like real quick I'll
render my scene and you guys can see
here that this this train indeed has
motion blur but I need to give those
lights to the trains so I'm gonna switch
out I think I'm gonna switch out this
train real quick let's delete that train
and let's make this make sure this train
looks good with all the lights and
everything
why doesn't it have lights
what happened materials
man that's frustrating I think this this
train asset is all over the place I only
need two of those tags
let me just check these material
selections real quick because something
something is up alright so it looks like
for this cab specifically this one is
actually getting the materials but we
want this to be true for all of the cabs
I think that might just have to be
something we skipped for now because
that's gonna be just a long tedious
process of getting all that stuff lined
up and everything but I do want this
train the entire train to be chrome and
for some reason it's not doing that
I do not know why that's just gonna be
mmm it's gonna be a minute I'm gonna go
ahead and render this thing guys and
I'll undo the deletion of that last
train
there we go all right go back to frame
number one hop into that camera and
let's set up our render settings here so
it's thing about this octane all frames
yes please and for our sake of PNG is
fine with alpha
all right and we should be good and
let's see let's do for the sake of
seeing something on the stream you know
let's just go 200 samples and we'll
select the camera tag we'll go to camera
imager will drop down spectral AI D
noise R and enable it and let's make
sure ooh here's one last one last idea
so this door is being opened right let's
see if we can open something along with
that real door so I'm gonna go to the
frame where the door is closed here
right the actual door and let's go to
geometry okay let's let's spawn a cube
right so actually we'll actually cover
it with something here and I'm gonna
take the HDRI image and make it a little
brighter I feel like it needs to be a
little bit brighter so we'll go back to
scene we'll go to node view we'll grab
that color correction and we'll just
take it up to like I will take it up to
like two or something okay and then
let's take the gizmo I'm gonna hit L oh
it doesn't work if it's not editable so
we hit see when we get editable I'm
gonna hit L move the gizmo over so it
swivels from that side and let's see if
we can't make a keyframe here and when
the door opens like this we actually
open up and reveal all this from the
inside and we'll take the cube we'll
give it an octane camera tag visibility
it's not camera visible but it is shadow
visible so you can see how that closed
the door kind of darkens up our scene
it's being led by those lights from
above maybe we can take those lights
down
so these octane lights will take down to
like 12.5 and when the door opens it's
letting in all of this daylight from the
actual HDRI image and let me just see if
I can once the door opens we wanted to
kind of fade out oh it didn't save okay
I need I didn't make the key frame
so it opens up
make the key frame and then we can just
kind of open it up all the way and scoot
it over make that key frame so it's
actually being opened that still looks
dim if I turn off these lights why is it
dark why is it dark it shouldn't be dark
let me double check my HDRI settings
again guys this is all just a whole
bunch of of problem solving okay so
you're asking how to make custom buttons
how to how to set up custom buttons so
you can hit shift C and look up anything
you want like this axis Center tool you
can drag it and drop it and it'll make a
new button right there just like that
you can also go to the window
customization customize commands and you
can do the same thing here you can look
up like set selection and you can drag
it drop it in there but since already
have one if you hit this checkbox edit
palettes you can like come up in here
and double click it I think will erase
it yep and then you can even add these
icons separators or group separators to
add you know like these little spaces
between everything but make sure you go
to window and you save your layout if
you don't save your layout cinema4d
won't open up with those new buttons so
just make sure you do that now why on
earth is it black now
so the lights are giving us something
but I don't I don't know why it's just
completely dark like this
hmm
I did set my octane sky brightness to
zero by mistake oh man thank you thank
you thank you
sweet yeah so it opens it up and reveals
our scene in here that's great
and let's get those lights back in
awesome and I'm just gonna drop the tile
texture on the other side
something like that and then we'll do
we'll set that selection
all right so it's on there
I also feel like doing a clay render of
this would be cool too so we just get
rid of all that and it's just like the
actual clay render
but nah well we'll bring everything back
all right
so let's go and render this thing we can
start from frame 100
and let's give it a render
so I think the biggest issue or not
issue but the biggest hurdle in
after-effects is to combine the edges to
mix to blend the edges properly so one
trick we could do is actually bevel the
edges of this plane here that way it
catches some of the light and it bleeds
off into the actual metal texture
another way would be to create like a
little cutout in the metal texture in 3d
and then kind of inset our room back
inside of that and expand it out so
there isn't a seamless blend from the
metal of this electrical socket to the
tiles because I don't think you can
really do that it's gonna have to be a
hard line at some point
and for the sake of getting the most
frames out of this I'm going to lower
the render resolution so we'll do 960 by
540 instead and we'll take the samples
to just like 150 and we'll render that
and we do have the AI denoising turned
on with the camera all right so as soon
as we get a frame out of this I'll load
it back into After Effects but basically
what we'll have to do here is we're
gonna have to we're got the rotoscope
this this little door this panel here so
that we reveal our render underneath
and it makes it pretty easy because the
things already tracked so let me show
you guys how to set up a track mat let's
take that floor and let's hit control
shift Y to go into our solid settings
we'll make it black and I'm just gonna
scale it up so it covers the entire
little like door panel there we're going
to be row toeing right so let's see if
the pen tool lines up with what we're
doing here and it looks like it does
okay great let me set the floor
opacity to zero and since the the floor
is actually tracked onto our footage we
don't have to animate a mask that's the
idea of a of a track map it saves you a
lot of time so let's go to the first
frame like right about right about here
I think and let's just make let's
uncheck rotor bezzie a and go through
and just make a couple points we'll go
one and let's try point here
and I'm holding all to just adjust one
of those little arms and I'll wrap it up
like that okay so now when we turn this
on I think at this point we can load in
our footage so I'll double click in the
project window let's load in our footage
import you want to make sure interpret
footage main you want to make sure that
your frame 8 is the same as the frame
rate on your footage ok so that's that's
one to remember
and you want to make sure it's set to
straight unmad 'add that way you don't
get any weird haloing around your your
CG object so I'm gonna drop this in
above our footage and we'll bring it to
frame 100 because that's where we
started our render from and since it's
tiny like this we need to hit shift F
and that will fit it to the composition
it's very low poly right or low samples
right now but that's about all we can
afford in terms of time for this for
this stream so let me just set this up
real quick if we right click the image
sequence we just brought in and we go to
time enable time of your mapping and
scale that all the way out we can turn
off time remapping and now every time we
right-click this and reload our footage
it's automatically going to update down
here we don't have to keep dragging it
out every time
so let's scrub and make sure that
everything lines up it looks like it's
not lining up with our camera so I think
that's going to be let's see we started
from frame 100 we're on frame 100
so I think we'll just have to adjust
this when we have a bit more frames
that's it's gonna take a minute to
figure out what the issue is there but
let's let's focus on one thing at a time
here the track Matt okay we we want to
have this door wrote out on top of our
footage here so let's duplicate our
footage bring it above our render okay
and now we have this layer here this is
our roto layer and we want our footage
to reference that so with this solid
above our footage we can set our footage
to alpha Matt and now it's just going to
be this little door here okay you can
see our render is peeking through down
here so we'll probably have to adjust
our you know back in back in cinema 4d
you will have to adjust this box here so
that it kind of goes in and follows the
contours of this little panel same four
back here actually back here is not
going to matter too much because we can
take floor mat and just move it back
here
so now let's let's keyframe this mask on
the solid here so that it moves along
with the door so I'm just gonna go
forward shift page down goes forward ten
frames so I'm gonna keep going forward
I'll set this to none it's easier to see
that way and I'm gonna just keep moving
forward here every ten frames making
sure that this stays shift page down and
the good thing about going every 10
frames is that if you can get it looking
nice every 10 frames
there's gonna be times where all those
frames in between the 10 frames they
just work out and they look right and
then you don't have to do it frame by
frame because you know you're getting it
you're starting general and then you're
working it in and getting more specific
so I'll get the in-between frames next
so it'll be every 5 frames but right now
I'm going every 10 frames to get it to
look right
and if my if it's hard to see this mask
you can change the color down here you
just go black alright that might also be
hard to see I'll just set it to like a
bright yellow and that's a lot easier so
keep moving
and that should do it that should do it
right there we'll probably need to get
in here and row to this as well so it's
gonna require a bit of roto work to get
this looking right so let's go back
every five frames I'm gonna go one two
three four five that's page up and I'm
going to go through here and make sure
all this stuff kind of aligns itself and
now I'm gonna go every 10 frames which
gets us in between these key frames down
here hopefully that makes sense to you
guys
keep going back and you can see how like
it's basically lined up the hard work
has been done and we go through make
sure things are looking good
then you can go every like three frames
so you go in between those to make sure
it's looking good so we'll go to those
in betweens and we'll find any like like
this moment here where it's way off
we'll adjust it
for the most part you know here again
there's times we have to do it frame by
frame
like in this case when there's a lot of
movement we'll have to do a
frame-by-frame
but that looks good so let's bring the
opacity back up to it looks like let's
reload our render
and we'll set the mass to ad set it back
to add just maybe revealing our train
station now let me figure out why this
framerate is off so inside of cinema
there that's the issue frame rate it's
set to 24 so I think we need to set that
to 30 hit control D to check your
project settings FPS 30
let's try reading that now it should
line up with us now there's still a lot
of work to be done but I think you guys
get the idea I think you might be able
to take this idea and make something
really cool of your own
yeah you get a bunch of samples in here
you actually build this out so it looks
like a legit structure and it's actually
real and then you comp it in looking
real nice you guys can get some really
really cool effects but yeah I would
love to get to the point where I can do
this
to its completion it's just gonna take
way too long as you guys can see you
know we're already looking at man what
are we three hours in you know so this
can go for a week to be honest but I
hope these tools and these tips and
these ideas can help you guys you know
kick started on your own kind of fresh
interesting ideas and this is all again
based off of somebody who actually did
this in real life again we got a shout
out let's see
secret room behind so your room behind
outlets so it's a Japanese artist let's
go ahead and read up this is because
this is how I got the idea
his name is mozu 21 years old and he
does stuff like this
and you can see all the detail that can
go into this you know actually building
on a room with all the papers and the
air conditioning like this is so well
done that is awesome and he does a lot
of these oh wow it's just all of this
all the same post he does a whole lot of
that stuff so definitely check out mozu
because that's how I got the inspiration
for this effect let's reload our image
and see if it's working
it still looks like we need to align
some stuff up but it's all good again
that goes back into the week of work
that it's gonna take to really make this
thing shine okay
so I appreciate you guys joining me and
as you guys know as some of you know I
do a weekly challenge and I hold it for
for you guys and anybody a part of the
create with discord server so if you
guys hadn't joined one definitely
consider doing so because there's gonna
start to be some really interesting
prizes I'm trying to line up prizes for
you guys every week on this in the past
that we've done grace go gorillas
everyday material collection and that's
just straight-up like 250 bucks of some
of the greatest textures handmade by
those guys absolutely incredible very
useful we also did a giveaway for a car
shader set up by [ __ ] Mouse and he
spent the last year building that out so
I want to keep the prizes coming so
definitely start joining these these
contests these weekly creative
challenges so that you guys can start
winning some cool stuff and also
honestly like I think at the end of the
day it's so that we can learn and grow
and get better at the craft you know
we're trying to get better at so let's
go ahead and announce the winners of
last week's challenge first okay the
challenge was snow that was the prompt
that's all you guys had to go off of and
we got some pretty sweet results so let
me go ahead and pull those up for you
guys and announce these winners there's
always five there's five winners so
let's see let's see
all right
so first up first winner of this week's
weekly challenge with the prompt being
snow let's go ahead and open up the swag
ninja this guy rented this really really
cool scene very post-apocalyptic very
creepy
reminds me of the walking dead
you got the guard towers up here
spotlights coming down it's all snowy
got all the snow coming down and I
hadn't played the last of us two yet but
I could totally imagine this scene being
in that game nice work on the volumetric
spotlights good stuff and you have a
nice warm glow in this camp so it looks
like there's a lot of you know there's
people live in there there's a lot of
liveliness maybe on the other side of
this thing you're just wondering you
know this guy's been out traveling for
who knows how long and finally got to a
spot is it a good spot is it a bad spot
I don't know but it's it's piqued my
interest so dissuade ninja
congratulations on your win this week
for the weekly challenge so you'll be
getting the weekly challenge winner role
on the discord server so congrats next
up we got David Katz with this image
here I really liked it
you rendered David rendered two images
but I picked the one that I felt was
best this feels really nice I actually
feel like pretty cozy in here it's
definitely cold and windy outside and
you can tell from this warm glow there's
probably a fireplace going on the inside
which is great you have a map here and
again there's kind of a story going on
here it looks I don't know what this is
maybe it's a photo book or something but
there's a story and again it piques my
interest I'm wondering where is this
person going did they spend all their
time getting to this point but I think I
think this is really nice I think you
did a good job here and I like your
lighting outside
I like your environment it feels very
nice so congrats to David Katz you are a
challenge when
this week next up guys we got mr. clay
boom this is awesome I really like your
lighting here I think he used though was
a world creator I think to get the this
really interesting landscape and I think
as far as I know world creator if I'm
right if you use world creator actually
sends out different like texture Maps
for you to say oh this parts snow this
parts rock and it's really really in
depth like comprehensive program that I
want to look into especially if I'm
gonna be getting into unreal but anyway
I really likes I like your colors you
got the snow down here and I really love
the way the mountains break up here and
you have the snow in the grooves of the
mountains so mr. clay congratulations
you are a challenge winner this week I
think it's your first one so extra
congratulations alright second from last
we have a render by visual this is
really cool you got this nice motion
down you got a spaceship back here
rushing through the scene you can tell
that it's kind of windy based on how the
snow is falling and this is a cool
little little cyborg thing here you've
got some nice colors some very very
subtle cool colors in the background
mixed with your warm tones in the
foreground that's looking very very nice
and visually you you always do a really
good job so congrats again on winning
this week's weekly challenge very very
nice last up last up I think this is
this person's second win I'm looking at
him right now in the chat he's sitting
right there and he has no idea because
there's a lag there's a delay between
what I'm saying and what you guys are
hearing but let's go ahead and congrats
salumi with this painting this is your
second win done with a with a painting
again and I really really like your work
here let me
do this so it why I don't know why it's
being dumb ignore this ignore this side
business over here okay this is awesome
it looks like you did this in Photoshop
and I love the vibes here it's it looks
like a speed painting I wonder how long
you did this in but you definitely got
the color and you got the emotion and it
feels very fun and I like how you
actually went with a painting instead of
a render because again at the end of the
day guys the whole point of this time is
to get better at what you love doing
right and Zaloom he loves painting so
you know he put in a painting for his
challenge and won for the second time
with another painting I'm really
impressed this is really cool
so congratulations salumi for winning
this week's weekly challenges so that's
it guys that's our five winners for the
weekly challenge and if you would like
to join the weekly challenge then I
suggest you just go ahead and do so
because it's not I mean it doesn't take
anything other than then you saying okay
let's let's do it this week you know to
sign up or anything the only thing you
need to do is follow the rules for the
weekly challenge which I'm about to dish
out right now for the next one and you
just have to submit it on the discord
server which there's a link in the
description below for you guys but oh
and that's Zulu meets a third time I
apologize so congrats to everybody let's
figure out this next challenge do we
want to do something along the lines of
like a secret world or something to tie
it along with today's stream or do we
want to do maybe we could do anything
secret world is kind of cool because
that way like it could be like a snow
globe it could be a tiny little room it
could be like The Lion the Witch and the
Wardrobe where you go through the
Wardrobe and go through the closet and
it goes into this different different
land you know or like Winnie the Pooh or
something
so maybe secret world is the challenge
this week I'm feeling that if you guys
are feeling that give me a thumbs up and
we'll do it
hmmm I think using the footage I mean
that if you guys want to go above and
beyond and try and use that footage it's
gonna be tough because like there's
gonna be a lot of compositing work to do
and if you just want to focus on the 3d
aspect I'm not gonna knock you for for
not using the footage but if you want to
use the footage you can and submit the
footage you know you've submit your
whole VFX shot that could be fine but
yeah let's do it secret secret yeah
secret world that is the prompt for this
week's weekly challenge the idea is just
to create some sort of secret world make
sure you don't just download some secret
world and render it and post it as your
submission that would be kind of lame
put some time into it and make it your
own
make it cool we just need a single image
it doesn't need to be a render or
anything or an animation rather you got
a you got a let's see
submit a clay render which is a render
without any textures and you need to
submit like a node tree or a viewport
just so I know that it's something that
you did right other than that I think I
think that's about it guys I don't know
if there's any specific directions or
specific notes or rules on this one it's
pretty self-explanatory I'm excited for
all the for all the entries I'm gonna
see throughout the week but yeah I hope
you guys had a good time I'm gonna get
to the store here and grab some barbecue
materials but I hope you guys enjoy your
Saturday enjoy your fourth if you're
celebrating if you're in America
otherwise enjoy your weekend and I'll
see you guys on the server throughout
the week and I'll be working hard on the
next corridor video in the meantime so
thank you guys I appreciate you and I
will see you all next week peace